all right so the Tesla cyber truck has
been kind of an enigma it was revealed 4
years ago almost to the day and ever
since then it was kind of quiet but then
we slowly started seeing them rolling
around like California a little bit and
then a couple in Texas and these were
like prototype cyber trucks and they
were testing turns out one of them was
me well for a day anyway so what we have
here is a near final Tesla cyber truck
uh it's not an actual delivery truck yet
it's still one that they've been testing
so there's some small small prototype
things here there but everything that
I'm about to show you is what's going to
show up in the customer delivery trucks
starting basically right now so uh I've
learned a lot about this truck in my
time testing it there are some
surprising things about it some features
that are really cool things that I think
truck people are really going to like
but also some concerns that I have some
surprises buckle up is going to be a
mega video get subscribed there's a lot
to it let's take a look at the the final
Tesla cyber
[Music]
truck all right first things first let's
get to the specs everyone wants to know
the official numbers everything on paper
and it's funny because we'll get to this
in a second but some things have
actually changed from the show truck
that showed up on stage including the
overall dimensions I'll get to that but
the stuff that you probably care about
is the basics like price range speed
right so there are going to be three
configurations of the Cyber Tru this one
that we're looking at here which you
can't tell by looking at it but this is
the triple motor version it's not quite
the same as the Plaid powertrain but it
is two in the rear one in the front and
uh it's going to be able to do 0 to 60
in 2.7 seconds an 11 second4 Mile it's
got about 845 h power it has torque
vectoring at the rear and uh it's absurd
they call it the Beast uh it's it's a
pretty ridiculous set of specs I think
that makes it the fastest production
pickup truck Factory ever but there's
also going to be a dual motor version
that they also start to ship early and
eventually also a single motor rear
wheel drive version the triple motor is
going to start at about $100,000 so this
is new information we kind of had a much
lower idea of what the price was going
to be at launch is a $100,000 truck
you're looking at expect somewhere
around 75 85,000 for the dual motor
version and then the single motor will
be further down the road but the dual
motor is still 600 plus horsepower and
still plenty fast but that's the general
Basics and as far as range we'll get to
the wheels in a second but it's about a
340 Mi max range from the absolute most
efficient version of this truck now a
couple other last numbers things that I
think some truck people will appreciate
first of all uh towing capacity and bed
capacity those are some things that
Tesla's told me I'm going to put the
numbers up here I think it's 2500 lb for
the bed which is pretty cool and we also
measure the truck because officially
it's about 5% smaller in every Dimension
from the original show truck the
Prototype that people have been seeing
on stage so I measured it from front to
back and it's about from Bumper to
Bumper 224 in uh we happen to have an
F-150 Lightning here that we've been
directly comparing it to it's right over
there we've got uh some onboard power
and all sorts of fun features here and
so I'll mention when things like that
also appear on this truck but it's about
the size of an F-150 Lightning a little
little bit smaller now speaking of the
5% shrinking Dimension wise there are a
lot of things that have changed about
this truck versus the original show car
from front to back there's a lot there's
a motorized front trunk there's so much
to talk about in this video there is the
world's largest windshield wiper which
I'm sure you're curious about so we'll
talk about that it does actually have
side view mirrors um they're
removable and they've kind of done all
that they possibly can to make it able
to be removed like you can take this off
it has to ship with this from the
factory legally um but there is a blind
spot monitoring lights inside the truck
there are
cameras uh here on the side of the truck
to show you that spot when you put your
blinker on so you can just pop this off
if you really wanted to and then also
down at the side here these wheels uh
this is an arrow cap that is removable
so let's just do that to start this is
the premium tire that's going to come on
a 20-in rim uh all the initial trucks
triple motor dual motor they'll all have
this tire on it looks like it's a
bespoke Goodyear tire it's got some neat
little aesthetic tweaks and I'm sure
compound tweaks and tread stuff here but
this is a plastic Arrow cap with like
this outside rubber it's actually a
two-piece and it'll get you a couple per
more range on the truck but if you don't
like the look of it or if you're
off-roading pop that off and that's how
the the truck's stock wheel will look a
lot of grease and metal in there but
this is a two-part thing like I said so
if I can rip this off these are the two
pieces and the reason it's two parts is
because they actually wanted these to
line up with the little rectang angles
on the tire so maybe you want to take
the a caps off to air down the tires and
go off-roading and you want maximum
brake cooling whatever you're doing but
if you want to put these back on you
sort of line all this
up and then you take the plastic
bit now you're
back get a shot of this get a shot of my
so I'm going to probably not do that
again considering uh everything it just
left on my hands but you get the idea
you can do that on all four tires 20-in
rims these again are the premium tires
and yeah okay great moving on so okay
you kind of can't really tell the story
of the Cyber truck without addressing
the fact that it is a giant stainless
steel triangle I mean it looks surreal
like there is not really a single curve
on this entire truck every single pie
these are giant pieces of stainless
steel there's all sorts of uh Sheen and
fingerprint implications that we'll talk
about but I don't know it it's an
aesthetic thing like not a whole lot of
Curves fine that's pretty cool but then
the other version of that conversation
is like look at how sharp the front of
the some of these pieces here how sharp
it is not that you're going to like walk
up and poke the front of someone's truck
very often but that's a sharp corner
piece of stainless steel right there and
right there and then this this front
piece here it's this one huge big
stamped piece and I had a couple
conversations with people engineers at
Tesla about using stainless steel on the
body panels like this and they have
these huge presses that are stamping the
stainless steel but steel has this sort
of a spring back effect so you use a lot
of force to stamp it in place and and it
Springs back really quickly so you have
to stamp further than you need to get it
to unspring back to the part that you
want it to be at it's a whole
complicated thing all of that is to say
I've seen a bunch of cyber trucks while
I've been here and they all have
slightly different levels of uh panel
gaps build quality in general this truck
in particular that we're looking at it
actually looks great I'm not going to
say it's Micron levels of precision or
anything like that but generally panel
gaps all the way around are pretty small
pretty even looks really good but I
don't know I don't know if I can promise
that for every truck like even just this
huge front piece here
has a little bit of like wavering it's
not quite a perfect Flatline so I'm not
an expert on it but I'm just saying this
is a truck you're probably not going to
care too much about looking exactly
perfect panel Gap wise all right the
next thing we got to talk about is the
the Cyber truck's trunk aka the truck
bed uh there's a lot going on here
actually look at this gigantic slope it
kind of it looks like a dump truck to me
but one thing you should know is first
of all
a dampened opening for the tailgate but
it's not a power opening tailgate so you
will have to manually close the thing
but it is a nice soft damp and then the
other side is the powered tono cover oh
wait I should do the thing they told me
it can support up to 300
lb
so they told me I could do it so here we
are I'm not going to jump but I'm told
300 lb of force from somebody standing
on one foot so I think if I jumped I
could probably break the thing but the
fact that I'm standing on it and it's
not braking that's pretty good and it's
a motorized Tel cover which
[Applause]
means pretty smooth I got to say now
once you're here there's a bunch of
stuff I got to talk about with this
trunk first things first you probably
notice it slid down and revealed a rear
window
uh which means number one yes there's a
rear window it doesn't go up and down
but at least you have that glass there
and two yes that means that when you
close the tunel cover you are completely
blocking your rear
visibility we'll get to that later so
the other thing you probably noticed is
when we first saw the cybertruck I did a
video about this on the autofocus
channel the bed was just like bare
stainless steel it looked kind of sick
it looked crazy uh but you'll notice now
it is fully lined Tesla said they took
it out and talked to some construction
people about it and we're like all right
what do you think of this truck what do
you think of the bed and they were like
this is awesome but the first thing I
would do is spray line this so I can not
damage it so they just figured they
would line it themselves nice thick
lining here um the bed size the official
length of the bed for the F-150 the
lightning got over there was 66 in on
paper now when I uh line this up here I
get all the way to 72 in so it's a solid
6 foot bed
uh but there's a little bit of overhang
over here so if I subtract a little bit
to account for that it's about the same
66 in and there's a little bit of a sub
trunk which is pretty cool to see so a
lot of EVS now have a sort of a sub
trunk area this one no different you can
definitely fit duffel bag in there
probably a full carry-on bag and there
is a drain plug so if you want to make a
cooler out of it and tailgate is a
pretty good vehicle to do
that there's also some bed lighting you
can see on the left and right there's
lotss of lights and there's also this uh
sort of a latch system so all sorts of
latch points where you can tie things
down with cables what you're probably
noticing though is there's no spare tire
no spare wheel if you do want one you
can buy one separately and tie it up in
the trunk but you don't get one by
default and then the other thing
is there's power in the trunk so 2 120
volts here and one 240 volt if you want
to charge a vehicle with a 9 Kow out you
can use literally the thing you'd plug
into a dryer Outlet you can plug that in
here plug it into a vehicle and give
battery to another EV so just in general
I'm glad that more EVS are doing this
having the ability to power other things
and actually charge you could actually
theoretically power your house with this
if you had the right inverter uh but 11
KW out of the charge port 9.6 KW out of
the 240 volt on on board all great stuff
to have uh I should also mention small
detail bottle cap opener over there and
then some more uh mounting points for
cables and things like that that's the
truck bed of the Cyber truck there's uh
some lights that we'll talk about in a
second but let's close the tunel
[Music]
cover oh something I just noticed if you
press the button it does the whole thing
or if you hold the button it goes until
you let go that's a
lie it was doing that up until that
point see
wait okay this is weird it didn't do it
that time but it seems like if I hold it
down whenever I Let Go it stops and if I
just press it it goes all the way until
I cancel it which it doesn't want to
cancel over there okay I'm learning in
real time close the whole thing tell me
when to
cancel
now I knew it all right we got to talk
about these doors cuz there's actually a
lot to it so first of all a lot of times
on a concept car or or a prototype
you'll see there's no door handles and
you're like oh that's cute but when you
ship the thing you're going to have door
handles eventually no door handles on
the cybertruck and they're sticking to
it I have my concerns about this so
basically how this works is there's a
little button right here that's indented
you press that button and when it's
unlocked it sort of pushes it out maybe
2 in then you grab in here and open the
whole door and then you close
it the auto presented Windows they all
close themselves up here they're
frameless Windows that's cool it works
same thing actually back here smaller
button you press it it opens it and it
works and this is actually a full 90°
door I love that there's like stainless
steel in here it's very clearly all
metal it's got a nice thk to it too but
what I've noticed and this is something
you'd already be thinking of if you live
in the northeast or something is if it's
cold or if it's raining or if it's
frozen if there's like an inch of ice
over here is this going to work Tesla's
telling me and this is a is a California
company that tells me these things but
they're telling me up to an inch of ice
if you can break through that ice and
press this button it'll push with enough
Force to open it and break the ice off I
hope that's true that's debatable we'll
see but the other thing about that is I
think a lot of people are going to open
it down here on the stainless steel and
you can see the fingerprints go so hard
when you open it like that and because
there's no door handles there there's
not really a good way of telling someone
how to get in so a lot of people are
just going to grab it right there and
fingerprint look at it's just tons of
fingerprints on the side here so I don't
know there's going to be a lot of cyber
trucks floating around with lots of
fingerprints around the place that
people's hands go to open the doors all
right front of the truck here couple
things that are of note first of all if
we go down low this plastic bumper
pretty solid but also there's two tow
hitch rigs on the front which is awesome
there is a front camera for the first
time ever in a Tesla believe it or not
that's useful on a truck like this where
you can't actually see over the front
then you have this huge daytime running
light but also the headlights the actual
headlights are just these slots down
here I'll show some night you'll see
some night driving footage so you'll see
what the headlights look like but then
the thing everybody's been asking about
and I've seen mostly on Twitter is is
there actually a front trunk in here if
so how big is it yes there's a front
trunk and it's automatically opening so
you just reach in and push the button in
like that and uh it's a pretty shallow
front trunk I got to say this is also
the part where I feel compelled to
mention that I haven't seen a single
Tesla logo yet on this entire truck it's
mostly branded with cyber truck in this
kind of a welded text which is kind of
cool but it's a pretty shallow front
trunk I mean I can sit in here and
you're probably seeing I'm much too
shaded right now so it's kind of tough
to understand how big it is but it's
only maybe the size of two of these
Ridge suitcases so I'm going to put two
Ridge carry-ons in the front of this
thing see if I can actually fit
both cuz this is basically the exact
size you'd want for like an airplane
overhead if you actually had to travel
with stuff in the front trunk could you
fit
it
not quite it's really close I think
maybe you might have to do some
Jenga to turn them down as long as
they're behind this seal I think I'm
good take
two okay so that's basically your exact
limit is two Ridge carons shout out to
Ridge for sponsoring this video so these
Ridge carons which are in these nice
colors they also have a 30% thicker
shell than a standard carry-on while
staying lightweight some nice carbon
fiber accents a durable and grippy
handle and they're weatherproof so
wherever you go if it's raining you're
good and if you want a matching Ridge
wallet it literally comes in the same
colors so you've got royal black Alpine
navy base camp orange and matte Olive
and shout out to Ridge for offering a
99-day risk-free trial so if you don't
like it for any reason within 99 days
you can literally send it back for a
refund no questions asked so check out
the bags the wallets and everything else
Ridge makes and get a special offer at
my link below or at ridge.com
MKBHD all right so now let's get to the
interior of the Cyber truck and once
again there's a lot going on but I think
probably the first thing you notice is
the only curve in the entire interior is
this steering wheel and yes it's a wheel
it's not a Yol I'm pretty sure when they
first showed the car one of the big
things they showed was it had had a yolk
and it had this crazy like marble Shelf
at the front now it's looking a lot more
uh normal carlik but there are still a
lot to go over so first of all this
glass this glass canopy from the nose of
the car basically all the way back to
right in front of my head is the single
largest piece of glass in the entire
automotive industry you tried to order a
piece of glass this big for your house
would be a big piece of glass but this
is the biggest windshield we've ever
seen and it kind of is is this nice
dramatic canopy when you're just like
looking around and visibility in the
truck is very good uh you also have
these uh little removable sun shades
that are actually pretty big and there's
this nice look at this magnetic
connector up top to get that in place so
that's cool and everything but aside
from that no other curves lots of
straight angles and triangles and things
like that a good amount of door storage
so I think you could fit probably two
water bottles in there there's some some
tray storage up here then you get up to
here and there's all four window
controls the door latch to
electronically open it but also the
emergency door latch open so if you lose
power every door that's electronically
latched has to have that manual opening
as well and then in the middle you've
got just kind of a bunch of open space I
kind of like the pedals down there I
think they're metal but then you have
just this big open tray space which I
believe the rivan also has
and then in front two wireless chargers
two cup holders a big old armrest in the
middle and a bunch of storage in here
including another 120 volt outlet and a
single 65 W USBC charging
port and then you're uh you're sort of
in the cabin and this is
where I think you kind of return to the
normal Tesla look which is very minimal
I do like this material better than what
they had before though it's
not the best build in the world Tesla's
been improving with their build quality
but it is what it is but you can
literally you can like lose something in
front of you like if I put like a like a
marble or a pizza box or something it it
could slide forward of course I could
accelerate and get it back but there's
just a ton of room and then I'm thinking
about visibility over the nose of the
car
man it's not great I feel like the more
I drive this car the more I'd get
accustomed to the size of it um but I
really don't feel like I'm looking right
down over the nose I'm looking out at
the end of the windshield and then sort
of guessing where the nose is so okay
couple other smaller things first of all
this uh light up here touch sensitive I
think that's pretty cool there's ambient
lights all the way around the cabin and
you can change the color of that with
RGB with software I'll get to the
software in a second there's also an
interior facing cabin camera and there
would normally be this is one of the
Prototype things but there would
normally be a regular rearview camera
here now as I mentioned you don't
actually get to see out the back from
the mirror if your Tel cover is closed
but there also is no camera option for
that that rear viw mirror to turn into a
feed from a camera instead that will
always be on the screen I think I found
that that's it's actually fine you just
sort of train yourself to glance at the
top of the screen instead of at where
the mirror normally is but that's
something to note and uh one more thing
what was I going to say oh yeah huge
tinted roof over your head all the way
back over the passenger heads and a ton
of speakers not a single curve to any of
the speaker grills but there are speaker
grills all over this cabin and they're
all either trapezoids or squares okay
something I've just realized I I thought
that it was require that the only actual
physical button you need in your car is
the hazards button this truck does not
have a hazards button it has a touch
sensitive hazards thing but then there's
also your Park reverse neutral and drive
gears if you actually want to change
them up above your
head uh I've never seen it there in any
car ever actually typically it's right
in front of you with the paddle shifters
or your gear selectors and you can still
do it on the screen like you can in
other Teslas but that that's new that's
definitely
new okay now the back seat of the
cybertruck it's weirder than you think
all right first of all I like that the
doors open 90° you get this seat back in
front of you really good rear leg room
mostly because the seat in front of me
is on these cool cyber truck looking
rectangular risers but that means I have
real space to put my feet under the seat
in front of me which is huge for leg
room so either side totally fine middle
not the best leg room ever but still a
totally great back seat got another
screen back here that I'll show you in a
second there's a little bit of seat back
storage but check this out there's a
little trick to the back seat just for
storage so although you already have a
front trunk and a rear trunk if you want
even more covered storage with this
latch right
here the right seat actually comes
completely up and you can just keep
stuff down here if there's no person
here matter of fact the left two seats
come over here also do the same thing
I'm going to get out and pull that latch
as
well and then that's just that's a ton
of room for activities look at this not
that that's better than having a seat
but you could put a bunch of boxes back
here you could put I don't know you can
just put stuff back here also there's
the 9 and 1/2 in screen for the
passengers which is where I
discovered you can move the passenger
seat not the driver's seat on the screen
and these are also heated left and right
not middle but heated left and right
rear seats they look ventilated they
look cool but they don't do that just uh
just
heat or you could just like watch a
movie or direct your airf
flow cool okay so whenever you're
talking about a new vehicle like this a
new platform like this you got to talk
vehicle controls so as I'm in the
driver's seat that's going to be this
new 18 1/2 in touchcreen in the center
biggest ever in a Tesla it's also the
biggest ever car and this steering wheel
which I got a lot to say about it but
you're going to notice it looks pretty
familiar to any other Tesla but they
have made some key changes that I think
uh I actually like a lot there's still
no stocks there's still no blinker
stocks still no Drive reverse all that
stuff but the buttons on the steering
wheel are at least now haptic like
actual buttons they're not haptic touch
controls where you touch it and it
vibrates to simulat a button now it
actually clicks and moves this time so
that's awesome so at least that's better
so that's the that's the blinkers on the
steering wheel that's your headlights
that's your giant windshield wiper which
I'll talk about and your voice controls
you still got your wheels up and down
for volume of media and your autopilot
controls and then this sort of a flat
squirkle I guess is what you'd call it
like a squared off Circle type thing for
the steering wheel oh and then
uh it's a real horn this time there's no
like button on the steering wheel horn
like in my car so I really appreciate
that also again no Tesla logo on the
steering wheel it's a cybertruck like
trapezoid silhouette type thing so again
I think the only Tesla logo in the whole
car is literally the key same as every
other Tesla but that brings us of course
to the new software so I think they've
done an actually really really good job
with the software and this allnew cyber
UI so if you've used a Tesla before it's
laid out the exact same way but it's all
themed in a very cybertruck way but
there's some new little things that
they've it's it's really well thought
out and I still honestly after using it
I really feel like Tesla has the best
software in the car industry that's not
carplay in Android auto so first of all
you you start with just this huge
cybertruck in the middle for all your
vehicle controls there's little hovering
dots so if you want to open the tailgate
gate or open the tono cover you can do
that with any of these little hovering
buttons open the charge for plap charge
charge port flap cool um but then all of
the rest of the looks about this car uh
you can adjust in real time so first of
all ride height you tap the wheel there
we are at the sort of a entry ride
height where it squats to be as easy as
possible to get into you can also go low
medium or high and it adjusts super fast
there's a pretty awesome 12 in of
suspension travel between the lowest
mode and the highest mode you can go all
the way up to 17 in of clearance in
off-road mode extract mode is the
absolute highest it'll add another 80 mm
of clearance but it'll go a foot down
from that so that's pretty sick and
there are aluminum skid plates SL Aros
Shields at the bottom of the truck I
continue to move around uh if I lower
the window for example look at the
window on the car halfway down halfway
down I go off all the way down on this
window all the way down on that window
so that's real time I get my lights in
real time I have uh the headlights down
here if I even turn the steering
wheel all of that moves in real time and
it's kind of on this like Mars terrain
cybert train whatever you want to call
it I think that's sweet so you just get
a full overview of the car there you've
got your media your navigation it's
telling me if I need to close my door or
fast my seat Bel and this is my range
indicator up here 223 Mi right now which
if I tap it is 76% battery pretty close
to what I'm expecting and then you see
your navigation which basically if you
just swipe over you can fill that right
2third of the screen with navigation and
keep your vehicle controls on the left
and when you're in drive that looks just
like it normally does in a Tesla with
other stuff on the road but now you have
all your navigation stuff you you always
have all your stuff in the dock down at
the bottom heated steering wheel with
two
levels which is nice now and your heated
and cooled front seats which is which is
great so if you just get into controls
and Dynamics these are sort of the two
spaces you'll spend the most time
controls is all the things with just
opening and closing unlocking screen
brightness headlights your glove box is
a drawer which I think is a little bit
unique a button on the screen I kind of
wish you still had a button to open the
glove box but all of that is here and
then Dynamics is where you have all of
your typical like steering and
acceleration profiles for Tesla so in
the triple motor version that would be
Comfort mode standard mode and beast
mode a little cringey I guess but that
is your maximum acceleration and then
your ride and handling and your
preferred ride height if you go custom
you can actually individually adjust
these things so acceleration I'm going
to go beast mode but ride in handling
maybe you want it to be a little more
relaxed or a little more focused that
just basically means your damping and
your suspension is either a little
firmer or a little softer I got to say
say though the steering is in my opinion
the craziest thing about the Tesla cyber
truck crazier than the design crazier
than the dimensions crazy than
everything else about it is the steering
so it's a steer by wire system this is
the first time Tesla's done this um you
can't actually change the steering
weight or steering feel it's always the
same ratio all the time but it's crazy
for two reasons one there is rear axle
steering and it is very very active and
really helpful and two is the total turn
is less than 180° for your maximum
tightest turn usually you're used to
doing a whole bunch of movement on the
wheel you don't have to do that anymore
so that kind of makes the muscle memory
of grabbing the top of the squirkle
useless so first of all the rear wheel
steer it's awesome it's up to 10° in the
opposite direction of the front wheels
at low speeds under 40 mph and what that
does if you've heard of this before it
effectively shortens the wheelbase and
allows you to turn way way tighter I
think we'll do a sort of a comparison
with the F-150 Lightning which is a
normal truck that doesn't have 10° of
rear wheel steer and this one it just
means you can turn way sharper it feels
way more Nimble in parking lots it it
feels like it shrinks the wheelbase the
whole dimensions of the truck it's great
it takes some getting used to but it's
very useful and then at higher speeds
above 40 m hour is when it actually
changes one or two degrees in the same
direction as the front wheels so that's
going to feel more like lengthening the
wheelbase and a more stable movement
changing between lanes at highway speed
stuff like that but the fact that your
entire steering radius is right there in
less than one turn like half a turn is
crazy it takes some getting used to it
it is awesome that you can turn around
so easily and make those tight parking
lot Maneuvers and make this big truck
feel smaller but it is it's really it's
a lot it's going to take some getting
used to but I think we should just get
to driving this thing so let's do it
let's let's drive the Cyber Tru all
right
driving the Tesla cyber
truck feels like a Doug mirror way to
start the video but man okay it still
doesn't really feel like a real vehicle
but it definitely is and first
impression really is well okay it feels
like a Tesla that's not going to be a
shocker really instant throttle response
this is the triple motor version It's
the Beast
um but also like spacing wise I'm just
looking around just trying to feel how
big this vehicle is this is a small Road
School Bus uh I'm able to maneuver
around though I have pretty good
visibility everywhere I'm just thinking
a lot about where the nose of the truck
is because it is such a short nose it's
a really
different different ratio I'm not used
to the hood being that short compared to
where the windshield is but either way
it's pretty quiet I will say these
laminated windows
do a good job of sealing out all the
noise they also happen to be
shatterproof the truck also happens to
be allegedly bulletproof I'm not testing
that in this video but you've seen the
pictures so the idea is it's it's really
well built I'm just trying to figure out
all right this feels Nimble right
steering is the weight's not going to
change so this is the way it always is
getting used to steering is really going
to be the number one thing for people
they're not going to be used to the
entire steering being less than an
entire turn it's a half a turn 180° I
think it's 170 and it is a pretty big
truck but it's I feel like it's a tiny
bit smaller than the F-150 Lightning I
think they did a good job of giving you
as much space as you can like this is a
spacious cabin spacious back seats as I
showed you and a full 6ft bed but it's
got the smallest frunk even smaller than
the smaller rivan
r1t so they've kind of pushed around the
dimensions a little bit but second thing
is just the vast distance between me and
the front of the windshield and then I
just straight up can't see the front of
the car I can't see the nose no matter
how high I look
that's just different very different
something I'm going to have to get used
to okay love that the
button blinkers are actually physical
buttons and now we're on a bit of a
crazier road so we can
holy come
on
that's crazy actually the suspension
pretty firm right now and there is a
large Delta between the firmest
suspension and the softest suspension
that you can have the body itself thanks
to the stainless steel thanks to the way
it's built is very very stiff
torsionally stiff it's very rigid and so
all of that effort to be either soft or
firm goes on the suspension and they
have a really good suspension really
good travel really fast travel it is it
really is very quiet okay couple other
interesting things that you note one is
like huge amount of glass world's
largest windshield is pretty funny I
think with every Tesla I've reviewed for
the past couple years there's always
been one muscle memory remap required to
get used to this thing and I think with
previous Teslas like we all know about
the center screen you're used to
checking right in front of you for the
speed now you have to look over to the
side just a little remap there with the
Yol steering wheel and the buttons on
the steering wheel that's a remap people
have to adjust to they're pretty
stubborn about this stuff with this one
it's going to be that there is no rear
visibility with the mirror when the
tunel cover is closed so my tunel cover
is closed right now can't see anything
behind me but I've sort of started to
remap my glance behind me to the preview
of the rear-facing camera which is on
the screen all the time and so I just
keep glancing there to see what's behind
me you can actually move it to the left
or right hand side so you get a bigger
preview when it's on the right or you
can just move it on the left so yeah
that's that's the cybertruck muscle
memory remap is your rear view mirror
doesn't have a camera mode so if you
want to check behind you while The
Tunnel cover's closed you're looking
down there all right we got a nice
little highway coming up I like
instinctively put my hand on this side
of the wheel to get ready for a big turn
but I don't have to do it
because so little so little turn all
right let's get on the
highway so you don't need a ton of horow
for uh regular pickup truck stuff but
merging onto a
highway makes a lot of sense let me uh
get some space between the car in front
of
me oh my God on all season
tires allterrain
tires shouldn't be able to do that uh
couple other interesting things though
about this truck one world's largest
windshield wiper is hilarious uh it
looks
ridiculous it it might be logistically
ridiculous too I don't know if in the
ice or the snow if it's going to to be
able to like break apart enough ice to
move that huge windshield wiper there's
probably a much bigger motor to move it
but it works so Nei if you're wondering
it doesn't quite cover the entire
windshield but it does go above my head
and cover 75% of what the passenger's
going to see too so I feel like it's
it's working at least and then the other
thing to note is for your road tripping
totally compatible with all the Tesla
superchargers it has all the autopilot
stuff that other Teslas have have but
it's also now an 800 volt architecture
and what that basically means is it's
able to charge faster at V4
superchargers and it's able to make
total wires thinner because they conduct
better and they're more efficient and so
the total wire weight of the car goes
down for all the high voltage systems it
also has a 48v low voltage system which
is four times the normal 12 volts you'd
see in most cars so in general this is
it feels future proof for that reason uh
but it'll still charge is just the same
as any other Tesla V3 and V2
superchargers a little more road noise
too you noticing little more little more
alterrain
tread coming through to the cabin these
B smoke tires I'm told do have foam in
them but you can still hear it and feel
it tiny bit of steering feel that's
weird Teslas are usually pretty numb but
this does have some steering feel now
probably the funniest most interesting
option that I'm told about with this
truck is the extended battery option so
all the Cyber trucks will have the same
123 KW hour battery size but as we all
know long road trips and towing and
Hauling things especially takes a toll
on your battery so there will be an
optional battery uh an add-on battery
that you put in the trunk that adds 120
Mi of range it also adds a ton of weight
cuz now you're hauling around a huge
battery but now you have close to a 400
450 M range truck which might be what
people need to haul big things if
they're going to work with it it's it's
interesting I really feel like the
biggest strength of the Cyber Tru is
it's got to be the the power the sheer
force of 2.7 second 0 to 60
8ish horsepower like no other truck
moves in a straight line like this one
does but I'm also going to include the
steering as a pro you got to get used to
it but again that tight turning radius
and how Nimble it feels like on a
highway that's remarkably responsive
like I can turn my wheel like this in a
Model S plaid and it does not feel as
responsive as this that's a crazy thing
to say so then it's
downside uh is going to be
one just that people think it's ugly and
that's fine a lot of people are going to
think it's ugly and two is it's more
expensive than we originally thought it
doesn't have that price Advantage I am
driving a $100,000 truck right now
there's no way around that the F-150
Lightning I'm following right now is
going to cost significantly less the
rivan r1t and on the Hummer are also
very expensive but it's no longer an
advantage that we might have thought it
was going to be now this isn't a review
I haven't towed anything with this I
haven't used any of the trailer features
I haven't filled it up with rocks and
mud and gotten it dirty I haven't
off-roaded at all there is a total
separate off-road mode in the thing I
haven't used I haven't Road tripped in
it I haven't lived with it I do have an
order so I plan on doing all that so
make sure you get subscribed to see the
full review of the cybertruck when it
comes out but I think generally as this
is my second Impressions ever and first
time ever driving the thing I think they
really got themselves something solid
here we're going to have to see about
fit and finish a lot of a lot of let's
see a lot of wait and see but I'm
impressed with this I'm impressed so let
me know what you think obviously there
are going to be some polarizing thoughts
on the looks let me know if you're in
the this thing is ugly and I'll never
buy it Camp why is this thing looking
like a stainless steel refrigerator on
Wheels I totally get it but let me know
what you think about cybertruck versus
F-150 Lightning versus rivan r1t let me
know if there are other things you want
to see in a video and get subscribed to
be among the first to see that
stuff I think that's about it for this
one thanks for watching catch you later
[Music]
peace